how does it make sense that
an nft of a board ape is worth two or
three hundred thousand dollars like what
would your response be to a civilian or
just somebody who's in the business but
not in the crypto business or in the
business world they don't understand why
are people paying that what's the answer
to that why are they paying that
yeah you know i i think it's um
you know
uh art
and and and
basically
creative intellectual property
you know there's so much creative
intellectual property you know
music tracks uh performances
media
icons
um you know homes whatever you know
there's lots of creative intellectual
property
and
i mean my high level perspective here is
that
um you know nfts represent
for the first time a way to
represent
digital and to represent digital
intellectual property
in a in in a in a scarce manner and to
have a monetization model around digital
intellectual property sort of we used to
have like drm you surely remember yeah
digital rights management which was it
was so annoying it was really awful but
like a
cryptographically provable kind of
ownership over some digital item is
actually really powerful can be used in
a lot of different ways now
why are specific you know a collection
of apes as an example why are those
worth so much i mean i think
this is you know
why did uh a series of pieces of art by
a particular artist in a particular city
become extraordinarily valuable over
time because they were cultural memes
there was an influence the uh of
adorning it of uh owning it and i think
that's what you're seeing here you're
basically seeing an enormous amount of
crypto wealth there's 2.3 trillion
dollars of crypto wealth in the world
right now and you're seeing an enormous
amount of crypto wealth and it's a
moment in time
where the crypto wealthy can exp can be
patrons of what they believe to be
powerful memes at the moment and they
can own those memes
and on them forever and they actually
are speculative and they can they're
they're tradable and and all the other
things that come along with it
unlike
that painting on the wall there is a
liquid market but it's a really
difficult liquid market
you know
to deal with so you have both the
frictionlessness of these markets
uh as well as i think you know
uh uh these are these are you know
ways to value memes
uh and crazy and uh and trade them and
and the like and so it's you know again
it's technically it's just only recently
become possible that you can do these
kinds of things um yeah
there's going to have to be a reframing
of the accredited investor laws and who
gets to buy shares in companies uh the
sec has
been slowly evolving this there'll be a
test at some point you can take it seems
to become an accredited investor i don't
know if you have any updated information
on that but
uh my understanding is that they've been
charged with figuring it out this year
or next year
yeah maybe you could speak to yeah maybe
you could speak to accreditation laws
and if they did change
what the world would look like and how
much of this hand wringing would go away
yeah i mean it's a it's a huge topic
right and and i think there was progress
made on this um you know last last year
when when when the updates to the
exemptions in terms of
cf reggae plus kind of came along there
was some you know a commitment to work
on the accreditation definitions um i
don't have specific information around
what might come and what it will be and
when but yeah the concept of a test you
can take uh you know
you know
it it's something that
i i think
it needs a bigger overhaul than that
clearly um you know the the internet has
been so powerful
at
you know dealing with risk and
reputation right i mean i i think and
the internet's done it
through platforms that
um
empower everyday people to make a
risk-based decision based on the the
kind of the wisdom of the crowd if you
will i mean um why would i trust someone
who's selling something on ebay well
eventually there were ways to to deal
with the the kind of risk through
both community policing as well as
ultimately things like machine learning
and other data
you know
the the concept that you would just get
into a stranger's car
and like or allow strangers to just come
stay in your house or whatever these are
absurd ideas and you know historically
you would have thought well you know
that's like
that's why we have like a formal
hospitality industry or that's why we
have you know uh you know certified taxi
drivers because we need to have
background checks we need to have all
these things well it turns out that you
can do these things
very very efficiently over the internet
with the data that we have
and i think the same thing kind of
applies
in this realm of of investing and i
think it's it's it's quite quite
reasonable that people who have
the ability to spend the time to learn
something
and uh and be educated can make really
informed decisions and it doesn't have
to do with how wealthy they are
in today's startup landscape committing
to security and compliance is vital for
growth and proof of your company's
security posture has never been more
important as you scale you might start
to receive more sock 2 requests from
customers and that's where drata comes
in drata is an advanced automation
platform used by some of the world's
leading chief information security
officers or csos strata will help you
successfully meet requirements support
enterprise deal flow and continually
track compliance strata also helps
customers easily prepare for and clear
sock 2 and other audits so you can go
from zero to audit ready in a matter of
weeks need more take it from philip
martin chief security officer at
coinbase and here's his quote it became
clear to me right away that drata is an
engineering powerhouse the solution
they've developed is well ahead of other
market players their approach to deep
native integrations provides users with
the most advanced automation available
so check out drata's five-star reviews
on g2 and see why companies like clearco
smart recruiter and the good face
project work withdrawda for their
compliance needs twist listeners can get
15 off and waived implementation fees at
drata.com twist d-r-a-t-a dot com slash
twist